this chapter wings over Kittyhawk the story of
Wilbur and Orville right in the beginning there
were the birds from earliest times men sought
to emulate their flight legendary Icarus made
wings of feathers and wax they carried him to
destruction Leonardo da Vinci inherited the
dangerous dream in 15th century Italy he made
sketches of devices with which he hoped men
would saw like the winged creatures of the air
da Vinci never flew but he was a genius far in
advance of his time indicating the principles
of modern aviation the next step was taken in
18th century France de Rozier a daredevil went up
in a balloon constructed by the brothers Mongol
ta man thus broke his links to the earth the
dream of flights had become a reality balloons
were far from da Vinci's vision of bird-like
flight to solve that problem new geniuses were
needed however balloons were useful during
the American Civil War Thaddeus Lowe built
a balloon from which he sketched the first aerial
reconnaissance maps in military history then back
to the concept of wings lilienthal in Germany
and Chanute in America proved that men could
soar like birds but they failed to uncover the
basic secrets of aviation that task remained for
Wilbur and Orville Wright the brothers had little
education little money for experiments but they
had genius in their bicycle shop they made a
glider twisting a bit of paper they realized
the gliders wings could be made to tilt to
the wind in the same way as birds Kitty Hawk
North Carolina the Wright brothers came here in
nineteen one to test their new glider it didn't
fly well they left Kitty Hawk discouraged in
December nineteen three they returned two years
of feverish work had solved the mysteries of lift
and control of motors and propellers are they all
won the toss to decide which would fly first and
became the first human ever to pilot an airplane
few newspapers printed the announcement of the
historic flight most editors scoffed at that time
the President of the United States was Theodore
Roosevelt the Wright brothers offered their
invention to Roosevelt's War Department officials
refused to believe their claims the airplane was
turned down but in France the rights were famous
kings and prime ministers were at the field when
Wilbur demonstrated the plane near pellit he won
medals and prizes almost simultaneously after
Teddy Roosevelt intervened a demonstration was
made for the United States Army if the plane flew
ten miles and met other qualifications the army
would buy it for $25,000 only a few Americans had
ever seen an airplane when Orville Wright started
the engine some eminent scientists still claimed
human flight was impossible accompanied by an army
officer Orville took the pilot's seat for the army
it was the beginning of a great Air Force for the
Wright brothers it was recognition after years of
ridicule and scorn for the unlocker some of whom
wept with emotion it was a breathtaking miracle
a year later the right airplane company was
formed soon new names were added to the roster
of American airman Glenn Curtis gave the world
its first hydroplane in France Louie Blair II
Oh a friend and admirer of the right prepared
for a flight across the English Channel he took
off without a compass setting a course for the
cliffs of Dover a man with wings obliterating
national boundaries it was a hint of things to
come then with the death of Wilbur Wright in
1912 a tragic setback for aviation Orville sold
the company crushed by his loss they had been
inseparable now he was alone then came the first
world war foot soldiers might go on marching but
this war was different from any previous war
in history made more deadly but the presence
of aircraft in the sky machine guns chattered
over the lines as the airplane met its rival a
balloon and proved its superiority bombers took
off with cargoes of destruction Orville Wright
now an American Air Force Major had thought the
airplane would bring peace to the world yet there
was one consolation in the war min had grown their
wings the war ended in the bright dawn of the air
age with the end of the war the world went air
minded plunged into a period of wild experiments
dwarf a'right still grieving the death of his
brother the parade of fantastic machines that
would never fly seems like a mockery of their
great invention it was a field day for crackpot
inventors men imitated the Greek legend of Icarus
with results more ludicrous than tragic but
Orville didn't laugh at the clowns the experiments
could be deadly men of courage gave their lives in
payment for scientific knowledge in airplanes and
gliders they rode their wings to disaster but out
of it came progress Charles Lindbergh in 1927
took off alone and a flight to France in Paris
huge crowds turned out to greet the Lone Eagle
first human to span the Atlantic non-stop two
weeks before the Frenchman Unga say and Kohli
attempted to fly the Atlantic in the opposite
direction from Paris to New York they were lost
in the ocean with a plane named for the ill-fated
pair another Paris to New York flight was
attempted successfully by costi and Belle aunty
in 1928 the Pacific was spanned by air for
the first time by an Australian Kingsford
Smith that year was the 25th anniversary of the
Wright's first flight with Amelia Earhart and
other famous fliers present Orville was honored
at Kitty Hawk it was a bittersweet moment for
our the oldest ceremony was tinged with sorrow
if only Wilbur could be here to share in the
glory more honors in 1929 the Distinguished Flying
Cross for the achievement at Kitty Hawk meanwhile
man's wings kept shrinking the earth post and
Getty circled the world in eight days unable
to foresee her own tragic end Amelia Earhart
predicted the day when wings would make the
people of the world neighbors or they'll share
that dream he spoke of it in 1938 with Henry
Ford another pioneer of aviation the vision
was interrupted by the realities of World War
two with President Roosevelt in 1940 Orville
inspected the new army planes at Wright Field
Marvel had played an important part
in the development since Kitty Hawk
after his brother's death he had invented
the split wing flaps for modern fighting
planes streaking over German skies manned
by a new generation of brave Americans the
bombers sped through nightmares of flak to
reach their target millions of tons of high
explosives poured down to crippled German
industries backbone of the Nazi war machine
speedy fighter plane strafe the enemy's
lines of communication they created havoc
behind the front air power gift of the
Wright brothers the decisive factor in
the free world's fight for survival against
the Nazis reviewing troops in 1945 Orville
Wright expected great peacetime progress
the age of jet propulsion had arrived
seventy-four years old right had lived to
see planes develop into sleek monsters flying
hundreds of miles per hour faster and faster
they flew aiming for a new goal the sound barrier
meanwhile civilian air transport had kept pace
our bills vision of peaceful wings for mankind
had come true beyond his wildest dreams the new
airliners provided luxuries that dazzle the old
pioneer man's wings had welded the earth into
a single unit the distance between New York and
Paris and Tokyo could now be reckoned in hours
modern wings cast their shadow over the ancient
pyramids and over the Alaskan wilds then came
January 1948 and Orville Wright passed away he
and his brother left behind a staggering heritage
they had given to mankind the most destructive
weapon of war short of the atomic bomb but the
huge planes were also cargo carriers a blessing in
peacetime troop-carrying helicopters could also
carry passengers and airmail screaming across
the sky to smash the sound barrier the new jet
propelled planes could become instruments of life
or death depending on how menus them at Kitty Hawk
stands a monument to Wilbur and Orville Wright's
here for the first time with success men spread
their wings and fluttered feebly into the sky
fifty years later men had gone on to
explore the realms beyond into the dizzy
heights of space onward for the planets
there lies the new course for brave men
with wings up there is the everlasting
monument to Wilbur and Orville Wright